okay so welcome thank you for coming and
I also want to thank Roger Hertog for
supporting the Hertog program this is a
research program some of the students in
the program are in the audience tonight
who are doing original research and the
subject of religious violence and
apocalyptic movements as you know many
of you that this is a program where each
summer we look at a different challenge
it's global in scope and transnational
in nature and so next year we're going
to be looking at climate change but I'm
particularly pleased to have Omer Bart
ah've here tonight to address the
subject of religious violence he is as
many of you already know one of the
world's foremost authorities on the
subject of the Holocaust and genocide
more generally but he's much more than
that he's made incredibly important
contributions to our understanding of a
whole range of subjects and as I think
you'll probably hear tonight some of it
comes out of his own background his
family background and and one of the
things I just heard today that I hadn't
thought of much before was how it is
that he began working when he started
out as a historian on the verum Act and
he points out that like a lot of having
in fact unlike a lot of scholars in the
1970s and 80s he was one who had
performed military service himself in
the Israeli Defense Forces and it was I
think and it makes sense it was partly
because of that training that background
that he brought a knowledge of of
military training regimentation
literally that I think helped him in
that subject and helped many of us then
to understand better that terrible
history it was from there that he began
to work more and more directly on the
subject of of the Holocaust and in more
recent years I think he's really helped
people to understand how it had a very
different nature in Eastern Europe and
it did in in the West in many ways that
history was even more terrible than the
history that was more familiar to people
in
period so he's gone on and and gone even
deeper in looking at the the history of
particular communities that's something
we're going to hear about tonight and in
fact he's begun to do the history of the
long DeRay and looking at the history of
this place over a period of centuries
and so so I'm just delighted to to
welcome him here he's received many
accolades I won't bore you by naming all
of them I just want to invite you to to
lend them a round of applause for coming
here tonight and addressing us so thank
you all mer well good evening thank you
all for coming here I will talk today
about a project that I'm in the midst of
writing I've been researching it for a
very long time about 16 years but I'm
finally writing it up and so what you
will hear today is a bit of a gist of it
it's very complex and to make it even
more complicated I will also be showing
a large number of images I will not
speak directly about them so you will
try I'm sure both to listen to what I'm
saying and to see the images and to make
the connection the book that I'm writing
is called the voice of your brother's
blood buchiach' biography of a town and
the name of the book comes as I'm sure
you know from Genesis but I will review
the relevant passage and God said to
Cain where is Abel your brother and he
said I don't know am I my brother's
keeper
and he said what have you done the voice
of your brother's blood is crying to me
from the ground now in spring 1944 the
territories sir
the small town of buchiach' erupted into
a wave of horrific violence
the german wehrmacht forced to retreat
from parts of Eastern Galicia in March
counter-attacks the following month and
drove back the Red Army buchiach' was
back under German rule for the next few
months this remote region of eastern
Poland now part of Western Ukraine
became the scene of Mayim and
devastation cruelty and suffering a last
chaotic appeal after three years of
total war and genocide the German
security police regional outpost
assisted by local Ukrainian auxiliary
units continued to hunt down and murder
Jews until it was finally dismantled as
the Gestapo vacated the scene some local
German officials along with commanders
of retreating combat units protected the
remnants of the Jewish population from
local militias and roaming bandits
disbanded auxilary Police and murderous
villagers throughout the spring and into
early summer even as the Red Army and
Verma were slaughtering each other
increasingly powerful Ukrainian
nationalist forces undertook a vast
ethnic cleansing operation against the
Polish communities of the province here
too the retreating Germans helped save
the poles of the eastern territories
loading them into trains heading toward
the relative safety of Poland's
heartland
when the Soviets finally broke through
the German lines in July 1944 they
launched a massive liquidation operation
geared to approve the military and
political Ukrainian nationalist
organizations seen as collaborators with
the German fascists and opponents of
Soviet power
what the Jews perceived as liberation
many Ukrainians saw as reoccupation the
soil of Eastern Galicia was soaked in
blood but who spilled the blood and for
what reason remains open to
interpretation of facin and Distortion
very little has been written on these
last months of German occupation an
early period of Soviet rule in poland's
eastern territories most german
documents were destroyed whilst soviet
records were inaccessible for many
decades pamphlets by Polish and
Ukrainian underground organizations are
scattered in various archival holdings
and provides fragmented and highly
partisan information but we do have
numerous witness reports in diaries
letters post war testimonies and
judicial records in fact these personal
perspectives offer an extraordinarily
rich source of information for the
entire world complementing official
records and then abling us to sketch a
detailed picture of genocide on the
local level historians have underused
these accounts viewing them both as too
subjective and too painful this has
greatly impoverished our understanding
of crucial aspects of World War 2 and
the Holocaust these are reports from
Hell on earth where there was little
room for pity and forgiveness yet they
also contain moments of sacrifice
compassion and humanness in June 1943
the Germans declared buchiach' and the
surrounding towns and villages
unify or clean of Jews all Jews not
employed on the few remaining
agricultural farms and labor camps could
be shot on sight many head in peasants
how
barns and sheds they had to pay a lot of
money to the peasants who were hiding
them wrote Elias Halfin 17 in a
testimony he deposited in the displaced
persons camp of light hime Germany in
November 1947 those peasants went to
town and sharped as they had never done
before this made things easy for the
Ukranian bandits who went straight to
the houses that had been pointed out to
them as hiding Jews and easily found
their hiding places and would
immediately execute them in the yard of
the house denouncing Jews he wrote at
the time reached unprecedented levels
the peasants themselves began murdering
and chasing them out
Esther Clinton 18 at the time record in
1997 The Twang called the Ukrainian
militia passed through the forced labour
farm where she had worked she whirled
them quoting hide in the toilet and
count the shots knowing by that how many
people were killed later
cossacks and others who had collaborated
with the germans appeared in the area
and began murdering the jews they did
not have enough guns so they hanged
people or killed them with an axis etc
they came to our camp with some
collaborators from the village they
locked us up in an empty barn they began
beating us they shot a line of people
with one bullet but the bullet didn't
reach me again I was put in a line and
again the bullet didn't reach me so they
began killing people with knives I was
stabbed three times the German army
doctor who treated green tile a few days
later said quote what did the Ukrainian
swine do to you pity and empathy were
rare though not entirely extinct
sentiments during those dark times they
stood out precisely because they were no
longer expected more often cruelty and
betrayal dominated the
spirits of the hunted alia clone Itsuki
wrote in his diary in 1943 the hatred of
the immediate surroundings knows no
boundaries millions of Jews have been
slaughtered and it is not yet satiated
he and his wife were denounced and
murdered shortly thereafter URC Minter's
diary contains references to quote
executions in the prison yard being
carried out mainly by ukrainian
policemen especially by a certain band
rszke who also liked to shoot people
saw a Jews on the street means it was
killed in 1943
yo elk at 17 at the end of the war
vividly recalled many years later how
the peasants surrounded this camp
shouting all the children out we're
going to kill you
some were killed with axes others put in
a row and shot with a single bullet he
stresses the Germans who came from the
front protected us from the Ukrainians
until the Russians arrived conflicting
memories of rescue and betrayal reflect
the chaos and vagaries of fortune at the
time ng Spielberg fleet man liberated at
the age of fourteen was hidden with her
family by a poor farmer with a wife and
four children later she was denounced by
Ukrainian workmate but the local German
commander escorted edge'
and her family to the Soviet line saying
I hope you all live well she recalled
that quote the Ukrainians were worse
than the Germans not least because in
her estimation 80% of her family were
killed by the Ukrainians who were our
friends by that time the Nazis had
orchestrated the murder of the vast
majority of the Jews in Galatia but
without these personal perspectives we
would have known close to nothing about
this period in 1948
spiegel 49 testified that in January
1944 Ukrainian militiamen murdered most
of the surviving 120 Jews on a farm
where he worked including his 14 year
old son it is important to state he
emphasized that this killing was not a
German action that he was performed by
Ukrainian policemen and bandits most
survivors of that Massacre were
butchered in yet another bandit attack
the child orphans stacked up in a pile
victims lying with open guts the local
German administrator had tried to
protect his workers when he left says
Spiegel the Jews earnestly cried but his
replacement a young German army officer
said to them as long as I'm here nothing
will happen to you we do not know the
name of this man and our only source of
information about him comes from the
Jews he saved a few hundred survivors
converged on the town of Twister near
buchiach' where the officer was
stationed until the Red Army arrived
most people think of the Holocaust as an
event of industrial killing symbolized
by Auschwitz a vast undertaking of
streamlined anonymous mass murder in
fact half of the total victims of the
final solution did not die in
extermination camps they were killed in
their own homes and streets cemeteries
and synagogues in nearby Hills forests
and ravines the killing was neither
anonymous nor streamlined the murderers
often.you their victims by name and saw
them face to face before they shot them
their deaths were bloody gruesome and
accompanied by many instances of
gratuitous cruelty the killers were not
only German police and SS or only
Germans of any
scription but also members of other
ethnic groups from the victims own
regions and towns often people they had
known for years as classmates and
colleagues and neighbors
there was nothing secret about these
events there were public routine
spectacles in which everyone played one
role or another in 2003 the Polish Yulia
Mikhaylovna Trimble recalled the German
crimes against the Jews I'm quoting how
they buried them alive and how these
people dug their own graves
she had the front rows view from the
street where I lived I could see how the
ground was moving over the people who
are not dead who was still not dead the
Ukrainian Maria Mihai leave now first
echo remembered looking out of a
classroom window and seeing quote a
crowd going around the municipal hall
toward the bridge surrounded by Gentiles
with dogs Gestapo and militia who were
hurrying toward the killing site there
were women men old people and young our
schoolmates and friends from the fall of
1942 to the end of 1943 she says the
Germans conducted round ups with
terrifying regularity they would arrive
on Thursday evening and work all night
and the next day as we hurried to school
we could see corpses of women men and
children lying on the road the Germans
would throw infants from balconies onto
the paved road they were lying in the
mud with smashed heads and spattered
brains
we could hear machine-gun fire from the
killing site perpetrator behavior is
often explained as a consequence of
dehumanization the obstacle to the
killing of innocence is removed by
perceiving them as non-human this view
of mass murder allows us to avoid any
fashion of the often ghastly encounter
between the killers and the kilt
clearing the way for detached analyses
of decision-making and the logistics of
genocide I have never bought into this
argument but in order to examine its
veracity I decided to investigate the
Holocaust in an entirely different way
not from the prism of Berlin and not
strictly through the eyes of either one
side or the other instead I chose to
reconstruct the event in its entirety as
it occurred in a single site selecting
the site had to do with its
representative value and the
availability of sources eventually I
packed a town whose name was familiar
but about which I knew very little
Bouchard was the hometown of Nobel Prize
laureate Schmo alias Eric Norn whose
stories I had studied in school in
Israel it was also as it happens my
mother's hometown although I had no
intention of writing a family history I
was intrigued however by the notion of
writing a biography of a town
a history through the eyes of the
protagonists and in this sense my
personal link to buchiach' clearly
motivated me the tension between
analytical detachment and empathetic
understanding was therefore built into
this book from its very origins no less
than 60,000 Jews were murdered in the
area of buchiach' and chuckles a nearby
town in which the security police
outpost was based accompanied by
mistresses and wives children and
parents who came to enjoy the raw
surroundings these 20 to 30 policemen
led a comfortable existence captured on
hundreds of photographs kept in West
German court archives
they were able assisted by up to 350
Ukrainian auxilary policemen along with
local town and village and dance and
Jewish policemen recruited and paid by
the Jewish Council from the local
perspective the Holocaust in buchiach'
was a series of extremely violent local
round ups assuming at times the
character of communal massacres about
half of the approximately 10,000 victims
were transported by train to the
Barretts
extermination camp where they were
gassed the other half were killed in
situ this reflected the fate of Eastern
Galicia as five hundred thousand Jews as
a whole 250,000 were gassed in budgets
while the rest were shot next to where
they lived most of this massive
bloodletting was accomplished within 18
months in an area measuring less than
half the size of the state of New York
for the Jews buchiach' was a shtetl as
were many other similar towns in Eastern
Europe this was a figment of Jewish law
historically the quaint shtetl featured
in Marc Chagall's paintings and the
stories of Sholem Aleichem never
actually existed the highest ratio of
Jewish population in buchiach' was
reached in the latter part of the 19th
century when Jews constituted some
two-thirds of the inhabitants the rest
being poles and Ukrainians on the eve of
World War one massive immigration caused
by growing poverty had diminished the
ratio of Jewish inhabitants to about
half of the total this was a
characteristic pattern throughout
Eastern Galicia where rural Ukrainians
constituted the majority of the
population while poles and Jews
dominated the towns and cities the mix
of populations meant the
the German genocide of the Jews took
place within a complex and increasingly
hostile web of ethnic religious
political and national affiliations in
implementing the final solution
throughout Europe the Germans adapted
with remarkable agility to a to vastly
different local circumstances yet these
circumstances largely determined the
manner
speed and scope of the killing as well
as its effects on the rest of the
population in studying the Holocaust on
the local level we discover that the
category of bystanders becomes
meaningless when an invading power joins
forces with local elements to murder a
segment of the population there are only
degrees of engagement ranging from full
cooperation to after rejection within
that context we can identify a prevalent
gray zone some who hide the persecuted
also denounced them some of the killers
also shelter some of the collaborators
turned to resistance claims of
indifference or passivity appear absurd
unless they encompass watching your
neighbors being shot and then taking
over the property for some of those not
targeted genocide proved profitable the
Ukrainian give nauseam teachers Viktor
Petrovich wrote in his unpublished diary
in January 1944 that while most people
in Bou church were experiencing quote
unprecedented destitution some people
who before the war were earning very
little make fortunes gaining more money
than they would have ever dreamed of in
the past
where's patrika virtue is the source of
this new wealth soon became clear as the
Red Army came closer he writes many
merchants craftsmen and so forth who
were living in
houses that had formerly belonged to the
Jews began moving out they anticipate
Jewish revenge he wrote the Germans
marched into lands with a long history
of both coexistence and conflict that
history had little to do with the
occupiers yet by necessity it played a
part in the implementation of genocide
even before World War one galicia had
been a site of contestation between
poles and Ukrainians whose origins can
be traced back to the 1600s for
centuries of Jewish settlement in the
area also left a legacy of often uneasy
relations and occasional outbursts of
violence the conduct of all local
protagonists during World War two was
therefore in some measure governed by
collective memories and acquired
perceptions and norms of behavior in the
book that I'm writing now I try to
explore the deep roots of local genocide
to reconstruct mass murder in a single
site and to examine competing post-war
narratives in judicial discourse memory
and commemoration in that sense this
book is a collective biography in that
it allows generations of buchiach'
residents to speak out it is
schizophrenic biography in that these
voices from the past often speak in very
different registers about themselves and
their neighbors it is a representative
biography in that it stands for an
entire universe of similar towns and
regions in Europe's eastern borderlands
a world that was wiped out and forgotten
the interest in that world cannot reside
only in the manner and causes of its
destruction it was rich and varied by
its own right we know
so little of it because the voices of
the inhabitants have been silenced by
letting them speak again I hope to
exemplify the richness of what had been
lost even as I investigate the reasons
for the disaster because we conjure
buchiach' back to life
the tragedy of its assassination is
better comprehended it is difficult to
mourn a life one never knew it is harder
to accept the loss of a life intimately
shared the final eruption of external
fraternal violence in World War two
seemed to many both shocking and
inevitable but that is reading history
backward to be sure there had been much
talk about the need for the unmixing of
incompatible peoples but no one could
have anticipated the scale and horror of
what came to pass still the question
must be asked why did such unprecedented
and gruesome violence seem at the same
time to be a natural outcome of past
events was this a problem from hell
as was said about the genocide in 1990s
Yugoslavia an expression of endemic
unstoppable violence were the various
ethnic groups just waiting for the right
moment to leap at each other's throats
this view was as inaccurate of
Yugoslavia as it is of towns such as
buchiach' it implies that some societies
are just prone to violence and there is
little that most civilized nations can
do about it yet the fact of the matter
is the 12 that was indeed internal
potential of an internal potential for
violence it was triggered by outside
invaders often representatives of those
self-proclaimed higher civilizations
whose goals determined independently
from those they occupied could only be a
cheese
by sword and blood the province that
came to be called Galicia following the
Austrian annexation of southeastern
Poland in 1772 had not experienced major
outbreaks of violence since the early
18th century and was to remain
relatively calm until World War one and
yet when the Germans arrived on the
scene in July 1941 they needed to do
very little at times nothing at all to
incite violence it is this shift from
coexistence to conflict that needs to be
explained in the book I try to trace the
roots of this precarious inter-ethnic
balance from the very foundations of
buchiach' in the late Middle Ages to its
final destruction in doing so I hope to
recreate the widely diverging narratives
of the past told by poles Ukrainians and
Jews throughout the intervening
centuries these starkly different
stories about the town they shared were
not necessarily antagonistic often each
group simply ignored the others as it 12
its own tales of history and myth memory
and legend yet the very present and
powerful underlying assertion of
cultural spiritual and material
difference did end up creating a sense
of an essential and unbridgeable defined
between the groups
some voices reaches with force and
clarity from the more distant opaque
past gnihton Hanover who wrote a book
called the abyss of despair or
translated into the abyss of despair a
vivid eyewitness account of the
devastation wrought by bok-dong
Magnitsky and his Cossacks in 1648
uprising against polish rule tells of
the polish and Jewish citizens of boo
Church fighting side-by-side on the
city's walls
the German tourist Olaf on valium who
visited boo Church in 1672 wrote that
despite its destruction by Ottoman
troops the town had been largely rebuilt
especially by the Jews who are very
numerous in this town that year the
piece of boo church was signed and that
the giant linden tree on a hill
overlooking the town where it still
stands between the turkish sultan and
the polish king but only four years
later the French traveller Francois
Poland le ROC reported that following
more fighting the Turks had accomplished
a lasting destruction of buchiach' yeah
the town was rebuilt once again when de
Larroque returned to it in 1684 he
observed that the athenian peasants had
put up their shacks quote next to the
gate of the city and under the guns of
the castle while within it the walls
live only Jews and some poles this was
to remain the demographic and
occupational pattern for the next 200
years the 18th century witnessed a
period of peace and prosperity ruled by
the immensely rich and notoriously
eccentric miko i pototsky a pattern of
religion of religion and the arts a
womanizer
a drinker and a brawler buchiach' be
gained it's impressive
town hall and monastery it also
experienced the arbitrary power of the
grand polish magnate as the poet
signaled current krichinsky wrote
pototsky
shot women on trees and baked Jews alive
much of what we know about the early
history of buchiach' comes from an
account published in 1882 by the priest
and historian said of branch a fanatical
Roman Catholic and devoted chronicler of
Armenian origin many of the documents he
cites was subsequently destroyed another
ardent collector
was the writer Agnon who's sprawling
posthumous account of buchiach'
overflows with tales of Hasidic rabbis
and treacherous followers of the false
messiah Shep tights V Allen's 18th
century boo Church seems to have nothing
in common with what branch writes say
for the identical location the Jewish
enlightenment or Haskalah
which promoted modern education and
greater social integration promised to
facilitate greater Jewish Christian
integration and indeed
Sammis Killeen from buchiach' ended up
as University educated scholars
assimilationists of Zionists but by the
19th century nationalism began to
infiltrate people's lives and whether it
came new criteria for distinguishing
between one group and another by the
late 1800s the central question was who
does the town the region the state
naturally and by right belong to espouse
and Ukrainians grappled with each other
over ownership of Galatia the Jews who
could only shift alliances for one group
to another found themselves in an
increasingly precarious no-man's land
until World War one the Habsburg Empire
managed relations between ethnic
national groups in Galatia relatively
effectively heated rhetoric rarely
transformed into physical violence
instead nationalism pushed for greater
literacy and stimulated cultural
activities political engagement and
economic progress all this changed
dramatically in the great war and the
national ideological struggles that
followed it little has been written on
the effect of the fighting in the east
on such ethnically mixed communities as
buchiach' the devastation was on a scale
scene since the 17th century tens of
thousands of soldiers were killed in
close proximity to boo Church which was
occupied twice by the Russians and
remained close to the front throughout
much of the war the Russian occupation
brought with it
murderous pogroms the unpublished diary
of Antonia chevensky headmaster of the
boys school in boo Church and an
anti-semitic Polish nationalists
provides an unparalleled view of this
town under the first Russian occupation
Joseph chevensky fled from in the face
of the second Russian offensive of
summer 1916 the Russian Jewish soldier I
believe arrived in buchiach' on the
heels of a victorious Cossack unit the
town he wrote presented quote a
terrifying picture of destruction
vandalism and cruelty he went on to
describe the gruesome consequences of
the pogrom that had just occurred there
s an skee author known to many of you
probably as author of the D book who
visited buchiach' in early 1917
described it as presenting quote the
tragic scene of a dead city rare
surviving Austrian and Russian documents
and photographs of wartime buchiach'
confirmed these impressions the end of
World War one did not bring to Galus did
not bring peace to Galatia as the
austro-hungarian Empire collapsed
Ukrainians and poles began fighting over
the province in the course of the
conflict which the poles quickly won
numerous Ukrainian atrocities against
polish civilians were widely reported
meanwhile a series of Polish pogroms
against Jewish communities prompted the
establishment of two international
Commission's of inquiry much of the
anti-jewish violence was linked to
allegations that the Jews were taking
the wrong side of the
conflict not taking any side at all or
professing Zionism whichever it was the
Jews clearly did not fit into the Polish
or Ukrainian visions of a new nation
state following yet another war between
Poland and Soviet Russia these national
ideological and inter-ethnic conflicts
left a bitter legacy of resentment
suspicion and rage Ukrainian hopes to
set up an independent state had been
dashed as they found themselves under
Polish rule polish attempts to colonize
the region were met with violent
Ukrainian resistance which led to
increasingly oppressive policies and
Jewish aspirations to integrate into
Poland encountered popular and official
opposition by the 1930s Ukrainian
nationalists were being trained in Nazi
Germany the Polish authorities were
instituting anti-semitic measures and
growing numbers of young Jews drifted
towards socialism and Zionism a mass of
police reports political pamphlets
personal letters and diaries and post
war memoirs reflect some of these trends
in buchiach' the town remains
politically and culturally vibrant
throughout the interwar period it has
far more restaurants and hotels cafes
and bars than one can find there today
in fact there's none there no such
figures as the historian of the Warsaw
Ghetto Emanuel Ringelblum and the Nazi
hunter Shimon recent town began their
lives there yet the mood was growing
darker Agnon who visited buchiach' in
1930 saw a Jewish community in decline
many were leaving communist party cells
were the only spaces where all three
ethnic groups interacted without
hindrance but they had their own violent
potential many younger Ukrainians were
joining the increasingly
Radek organization of Ukrainian
nationalists known as own when the
Soviets took over Galicia in 1939 a
brief moment of acceleration and hope
was followed by two years of political
terror and economic collapse driven by
suspicion of enemy nationalities social
classes and integral nationalists the
Soviets deported tens of thousands of
poles Jews and Ukrainians this was
oppression on an entirely new scale
followed by the mass execution of mostly
Ukrainian political prisoners just as
the Germans march in in July 1941 the
state ordered murders greatly
exacerbated inter-ethnic animosity and
played into the hands of the invading
Nazis who were quick to blame them on
the Jews the ensuing massacres of Jewish
populations can be traced back directly
to Soviet policies and Nazi propaganda
though they're deeper origins stretched
back at least to World War One as
anti-jewish violence became a daily
routine in German occupied buchiach'
this community of increasingly fragile
coexistence was transformed into a
community of genocide not all
protagonists confirm conformed to the
roles assigned to them in conventional
accounts if younger members of pre-war
Ukrainian nationalist organizations
became direct participants in Nazi
extermination policies older
conservative Ukrainian political and
religious leaders tried to prevent the
violence while pre-war polish elites had
supported the exclusion of Jews they
appear to have been more likely to
shelter Jews than either the Ukrainian
neighbors or poles in the Polish
heartland his peasants clearly took part
in the killing many Jewish survivors
were hidden
by poor peasants living on isolated
farms who received little or no
compensation finally while the Jews were
targeted as a group by the Germans
the buchiach' police the the the
butchered Jewish Council and police were
notorious for their corruption and
despised the stools of the Gestapo yet
several policemen eventually joined the
resistance the final phase of the
transformation of buchiach' into a sorry
the final phase of the transformation of
buchiach' into a homogeneous community
came with the return of the soviets on
the basis of previously inaccessible
documents I can reconstruct the
liquidation and deportation policies by
the NKVD in 1944 49 while large numbers
of Ukrainian fighters along with their
families were sent to gulag for exile to
Kazakhstan most of the surviving poles
was sent to Poland in a vast polish
Ukrainian population exchange the
brutalization of the war years also left
its marks investigations of the genocide
of the Jews often culminated in summary
justice Jewish survivor Rene Zubov
record in 1995 how as a little girl in
recently liberated buchiach' she and her
friends would go for our entertainment
to our daily hangings of the horrible
collaborators we saw them strung up and
I'd be in heaven there was none of all
these trials with witnesses one would
say he did it string him up the
inhabitants of contemptible church are
former Ukrainian residents and their
descendants villagers who moved into
town after the war and ethnic Ukrainians
deported from Poland most know very
little about their town's past the
Communists had subsumed the genocide of
the Jews
under a general narrative of Soviet
martyrdom and heroism
then you Western Ukrainian authorities
have reacted the nationalists of World
War two as heroic figures neglecting to
mention the role in the destruction of
the Polish and Jewish neighbors
thus the fate of the Jews has remained
outside the official narrative of the
past the survivors and exhales never
forgot their hometown communities of
memory around the world preserved their
separate narratives and passed them on
to their children a Memorial Association
in France wife has published a stream of
personal accounts by Polish survivors
the former mayor of buchiach' put
together a memorial book narrating the
history of the town and region from the
Ukrainian perspective the densely
written jewish memorial book contains
much valuable historical scholarship and
personal testimonies but almost nothing
about the christian inhabitants of the
town material remains in sites of
commemoration
similarly reflect the split and often
conflicting memories on the Federal Hill
where thousands of Jews were murdered a
large memorial to Ukrainian freedom
fighters has been erected on another
hill next to the famous linden tree a
new statute of Ukrainian nationalists
leader Stepan Bandera overlooks the town
there are no memorials to the Polish
population although boo church is filled
with edifices constructed and the Polish
and Habsburg rule but the Roman Catholic
Church was renovated by father Lucic
Rutina who returns from decades of exile
in Poland before his death in 2010 he
had succeeded in making it into a modest
new center of Roman Catholicism in a
predominantly Greek Catholic region
there's some reasons for why people
adopted Rome
Thorus isn't there but we can talk about
it later Jewish life is not revived in
boo Church and attempts to commemorate
the victims have been largely
unsuccessful a memorial put up by
survivors and the Jewish cemetery
immediately after the liberation was
removed by the Soviet authorities a
small memorial stone to the victims on
the Federal Hill which lay broken on the
fourth floor for decades was put up
again
some years ago but remains unmarked and
difficult to find as are the mass graves
of some five thousand Jews surrounding
it a new and unassuming memorial in the
Jewish cemetery is hidden from view and
already crumbling it seems to serve us
as a public toilet no information about
the Jews of buchiach' is available in
the town say for a few photos of Agnon
in the local museum a plaque put up next
to the author's former house does not
mention his Jewish identity here he
appears as a Ukrainian writer
thus the history of buchiach' and its
demise must be sought elsewhere
dozens of archives in Russia Ukraine
Austria Germany France Britain the
United States and Israel contained vast
amounts of information written in nine
languages on this little borderland town
German Court records provide especially
rich material on the period of the
Holocaust as to hundreds of written
audio tape and videotape testimonies of
survivors stored in Poland the United
States and Israel polish eyewitness
reports of Soviet deportations are
stored at the Hoover Institution
interviews with scores of local
Ukrainians exiled poles and surviving
Jews have proven to be a rich source for
reconstructing the fraud inter-ethnic
relations in the daily and the daily
life of genocide in buchiach' in 1995 I
interviewed my mother about
hometown boo touch for the first time
she spoke about her childhood and that
conversation set me off on this long
journey with planned to visit boo touch
together she had not been there since
leaving at the age of 11 in 1935 but not
long after the interview she fell ill
and passed away in 1998 when I finally
reached buchiach' I was glad that my
mother had not seen the erasure of
memory so blatantly displayed there but
I'm sorry the Chi and so many other
people with whom I spoke over the years
about the town they loved and who
recalled cherished memories of childhood
in a pre-war world that scenes from a
distance to have been an era of
innocence on the eve of destruction will
no longer be able to read this book that
I'm finally trying to finish thank you
so I mean but my first question it's a
maybe it has a long answer but those
images are just extraordinary and I
wonder you know having myself often had
to search for images to illustrate a
story and barely coming up with anything
like this I mean could you just
subscribe like what it took for you for
this part of your research it took
several things that I say one thing a
couple days ago I got an email from my
German research assistant Frank lenka
who had seen some on the Internet some
lecture that I gave and he said that he
was so pleased to see these images and
partly because he collected some of them
for me so I one thing is to have a
really good research assistant who
really knows the archives inside out
I found a fair number of them myself but
it just takes many years and engagement
with images which I developed as I was
doing this project I'm halfway through
through this project I got to know the
the layman authors say but not
personally but his writing and his use
of images and it spoke to me very much
so I became more and more interested and
so whenever I couldn't be in archive
speaking with people speaking giving
lectures I ended up with images I'll
give you just one example I gave a talk
in in Melbourne at Monash University and
this man came up to me after that and
said you know my mother was in Bou
church and this is an elderly man my
mother was in blue church in World War
one as a doctor and she was there just
for the war and later after the
the Revolution she went to Australia and
Australia they never recognised her
medical degree and she never worked as a
doctor again but she kept these
photographs and I asked her to have them
so he gave me these photographs and I
used here some photographs which are
from her collection they don't exist in
any archive whatsoever of the Russian
army hospital in buchiach' so it's just
because I get a talk there and this man
came up to me so what you find is that
there's this little town which is the
dot on the map that nobody ever heard of
if they didn't grow up in Israel and
even then they know nothing about it
they just heard the name and you talk
about it and you start acquiring more
and more both a lot of images and then a
lot of other what about the the other
dots on the map I mean if you could help
us I mean that's kind of part of for me
anyway what makes it all so overwhelming
is just the idea that that there are all
these other this was a medium-sized town
right and and so when you look at the
the larger context can you give us some
sense about what was unusual and and
what was typical about this especially
in terms of that I mean for me want one
of the things that so extraordinary is
this longer history of violence right
that goes back many decades before the
Holocaust and so yeah so yeah
medium-sized it depends how you compare
what you compare it to but it had let's
say ten thousand eight thousand
inhabitants over time in the 19th
century grows to about sixteen thousand
on when the Germans come there in 1941
they're about 8,000 Jews and 8,000 poles
in Ukrainian so all together just over
15,000 which is about the population of
the town today it's very similar to many
other towns in the region there are of
course differences some curious so one
difference is that this is
not a particularly hilly region but
buchiach' is built-in in this valley of
the stripper river so it has many hills
and that meant that when people had to
hide and they did it both say during the
Turkish siege in the late 17th century
and during the German occupation it was
easier to hide there because you could
dig from your house directly into the
mountain because the houses were built
on their own the slopes of the mountain
another thing that makes it different
from some other towns in the region is
that the next major town that I
mentioned short hauls and alcohol
Trotsky was a major Hasidic center and
butchart was not so in terms of Jewish
history there's a big difference between
them and there was competition between
them but by and large it's very similar
to a whole range of towns that in this
region had a mix of polish Ukrainian and
Jewish population now in terms of
violence what what one has to keep in
mind is two things a yes there is a
history of violence and that history of
violence is remembered collectively and
very differently by different
communities all the time and be most of
the time there's no violence there and
it is not a place where people are not
safe on the street my sense is that in
1910 walking down the street in boo
Church was probably safer than walking
down the street in New York the woods
everybody knew everybody there was no
and meant no incidents of crime with
something really rare but that does not
mean that it's harmonious because the
communities have very strong opinions
about each other in buchiach' and in the
region in general and those opinions
which become increasingly nationalized
so religion and nationalism start
working hand in hand then create a
potential for violence which is not of
this criminal nature although it becomes
but has an ideological aspect to it and
that kicks in particularly as I argue in
World War one so it's from World War one
that the the things change dramatically
a butcher chain in many many other towns
in this region both because of the
violence of the war which is extremely
violent there and we know you know we
all read stories about the Western Front
that's what most people in the West read
but the war there was extremely funny
and because the war ends with the fall
of the empires and the creation of
nation-states and these nation-states
see themselves as nation-states burdened
with these large minorities which they
want either to integrate or to kick out
okay I mean one thing it does seem I
mean it's not rare right but I mean
there was the the worst period was at
the very end when the Germans first are
driven back but then managed to not at
the very end but in 1944 they managed to
reoccupy this area is that something
where everywhere had happened was was
something that and then you know people
come out right they come out from hiding
yeah and then now they're they're
vulnerable
and almost all of them in this case
anyway are wiped out is that is that a
pattern that you've seen more broadly
well they this case is rather unique in
the sense that the Germans are pushed
out and then because of the turn of
military events that they come back what
is interesting here is that when they
are pushed out 800 no one has the exact
figure so it's somewhere between 600 and
a thousand so let's say 800 Jews who
were residents of buchiach' come out of
hiding now compared to a thousand that's
not an so great but compared to survival
rate in general in this region it's
quite extraordinary that so many had
survived so the first question is why
did so many succeed in surviving a
butcher
like other towns what was the cause and
different people give different answers
so some people say well it's because
there was a Jewish resistance and the
Jewish resistance had intimidated polish
and particularly you Ukrainian denounces
Jew hunters who denouncing Jews for
money to the Germans and they had tried
to assassinate them they killed a couple
of them and so the denounces were
intimidated another argument is the
opposite that in in buchiach' relations
before the war were better than in many
other towns and it is a fact that when
the Germans arrived in early July 1941
there is no massive pogrom in buchiach'
and there is in many other towns it does
not happen in buchiach' and it's not
that the Ukrainians don't take over they
do and there is violence but there's no
massive killing so that may be an
indication that in that town relations
were relatively better than in other
towns but but that is rather unique the
second aspect of it is of course that
then the Germans come back and when the
Germans come back all the people came
out of hiding
a the exhausted one has to understand
they were in hiding they're malnourished
they'd usually been in the holes in the
ground they cannot walk they're very
very weak so it's very hard for them to
escape the Soviets were retreating tell
them don't worry about it we'll be back
in in a day or two and of course they
don't come back between April and July
so and thirdly their hiding places are
no no so it's very easy to hunt them
down and most of them are killed within
the next first few days after the German
reoccupation so it gives you a whole
variety of aspects that are relatively
rare in most cases once the Germans left
they didn't come back and in these areas
it was just the the particular strange
events in that area that made that
possible okay thank you two questions
first of all when you talk about Galicia
in this period of 44 after I assume the
debris chin counter-offensive which the
Germans launched it propelled the Red
Army back east what I found
extraordinary is these incidents of
compassion from the Vermont because your
work of course has demolished been part
of demolishing that for the past 25 to
30 years and so when you look throughout
Galicia what it raised in my mind was
what else was going on I mean was just
particular to particularly units etc
were there other examples of this and
then the second thing you bring up a
Stepan Bandera who is you know put into
a concentration camp in July of 1941 by
the Germans but we know what along with
the splits does and oopah in terms of
everything that they do during the war
and after the war uh in terms of
anti-semitism and killing Jews so go
more into that you know because this
town is not the only town where a Stepan
Bandera monument is there's all
throughout Ukraine museums - Stepan
Bandera etc who's killed in 59 by the
KGB so that issue of memory you know
being revitalized its second Bond era
who's now the great hero is it's
fascinating
the first issue look I mean yes I was
talking about it earlier my I did spend
about 20 years saying that the famous
was was up to its ears in in killing and
murder and and nothing that I found out
here will prove otherwise
so I'm not trying to change people's
opinions about the conduct of the German
armed forces in general however this is
what happens when you do a study a close
study of one place you find that all the
truths
that maybe may hold in general become
more complicated it's just like we
generalize about humanity and then we
get to know an individual and they don't
quite fit our views of how people behave
they have their own original peculiar
traits so in this case we have two
elements that were not only in the case
of buchiach' and in fact the case of
these few German officers don't relate
only to buchiach' it's not happening in
boo Church it's just that some survivors
of that town benefit from it it's
happening in the eastern part of Eastern
Galicia there were agricultural farms
that were being run by the Germans and
in which Jews were working and it was
really the only place where they could
still survive because otherwise the area
was unified and they would be shot on
sight and there were good workers and
obviously they worked as hard as they
could because it was the only way to
survive and then the only culture
officers there create some sort of
relationship with them and this is
really what I was interested in seeing
they get to know them they they don't
see them as dehumanized Jews they see
them as people and they also get
particularly angry at these bandits and
these people who raid these farms and
kill people ray people asking for money
to buy vodka and they say that they will
not allow that to happen so whether
they're you defiantly whether they're
doing it because they love Jews or
because they have a particular
relationship with the people that
they're working with or they're really
angry at these bandits and hooligans
that's very hard to say the second
category of Germans who help combat
officers who are retreating now many of
them as I've written myself were
brutalized by the warned you can't
expect much good from them but it so
happens that some of them come there
they have not they know nothing about
the area that they're coming to and they
see these groups of people are just
being
- down by villagers by militias by
Vlasov soldiers there are a lot of
soldiers they call them Vlasov soldiers
it's former Russian soldiers who were
POWs who've been served in the German
army and have now deserted from the
German army and they are also raiding
and going while there and they say we
won't let that happen
I don't think this changes the fact that
the Germans are the organizers of the
genocide of the Jews but it does give it
a more complex picture and that's really
what I'm interested in the second is a
much bigger question about Bandera and
then their own looked at the own which
is formed in 1929 and then their own and
the will power buys the is the Ukrainian
insurgent army that is formed in 43
they are fascists organizations that are
dedicated to creating and Ukraine free
of powers and Jews and liberating it
from the Bolsheviks the main enemy as
they see it the the Soviets the
Communists and they identify Jews with
communists and the poles the the first
wave of violence is in for linea in the
province that is north of galicia where
they they conduct extraordinarily brutal
ethnic cleansing of pause now they also
kill a lot of Jews but most of the Jews
have already been killed by the Germans
so by the time their own Anupa become
active as killers of civilian
populations they're far more opposed to
be killed and Jews but when there are
Jews to kill they they participate in
that many members of these organizations
before that had served as German
policemen and they desert a mosque from
the German police and join the Ukrainian
insurgent army in 1943 and they're using
often techniques and killing poles and
Jews that they learned from
Germans because they help them in
killing the Jews that is an
extraordinary aspect of the violence
they're within whose context also the
Holocaust happen and it's continuing to
happening to happen the killing of the
Jews now after the war the Ukrainian
Nationals continued to resist the
Soviets well into the late 40s by the
late forties most of them are dead in as
you mentioned in 59 but they're I'm self
is assassinated but by then he's been
marginalized by Ukrainian nationalists
because he's really a bit of a weirdo
within the politics of memory in that
region
the Soviets of course don't allow any
talk about those Ukrainian freedom
fighters as freedom fighters they talk
about them as collaborators with the
sastras and of course they don't talk
about the Holocaust but they talk about
the killing of innocent Soviet civilians
there's a guidebook to Boutrous from
1985 that takes you to the hill on which
still there is a Jewish cemetery without
mentioning that you would be standing in
a Jewish cemetery and on a mass grave of
about 4,000 bodies and says in this town
eight thousand innocent Soviet civilians
were killed and it never mentions Jews
that's from 1985 so that was the Soviet
politics of memory once independent
Ukraine is created in 1991 in Western
Ukraine this is not something that
happens in eastern Ukraine in western
Ukraine in those areas that had come
under Russian Soviet rule only 39 and
then in 44
before that it was never under Russian
rule in those areas suddenly those
people who had been maligned
by the Soviets as collaborators with the
fascists reappear as national heroes
because they fought for Ukraine and
independence and they're linked to the
the period of 1919 to the first
Ukrainian Republic or Western
crane and Republic and that is linked to
Malinsky to the first uprising of the
Ukrainians although there were no
Ukrainians then but reading it backward
it appears like a Ukrainian uprising and
that creates a whole spate of memorials
as you say everywhere buchiach' in fact
got its memorial quite late because it's
poor it cost money to build this so it
took them a long time to raise funds to
put up this memorial now you go to
leaves there's a huge arc triumphal arc
and a huge monument to bad era if you go
to eastern ukraine people there still
speak about the rune Anupa as
collaborators so that's a politics of
memory of western ukraine it's still
very vibrant and it's still part of a
internal discussion in Ukraine about the
past and the future nature of that
country professor of all of the areas in
which local populations collaborated
there from the Baltic down all the way
to the Black Sea would you make the
argument that the Ukrainians are the
most involved with denial about what
happened to the Jewish population I'm
not sure you know this there's a really
fantastic book that will be published
soon which is about writing about the
Holocaust in post-communist Eastern
Europe and he goes country by country
talking about that so it's a little hard
to make these comparisons different
countries have dealt with it differently
Poland is you know has gone through a
great deal of conflict but by large has
gone a long way toward
recognizing not just well in fact not
particularly polish complicity but
rather Jewish history as part of Polish
history which maybe is a more important
element of this kind of politics of
memory in Lithuania there has been a
trend toward the right in the last few
years there was more openness and now
there's less Ukraine is is is it's
different in in several ways Ukraine was
part of Soviet Russia in a very
different way from the Baltic countries
of Poland Hungary or all of those
countries it was really part of Soviet
Russia and as I said earlier Ukraine
itself is somewhat conflicted about
where does it belong to east or west
Russia and then within Western Ukraine
there is a particular nationalist strain
which cause for glorification of the
nationalists who happen to have also
been genesee they're the same people who
fought bravely to liberate Ukraine and
in some ways they had a point but we're
also complicit in mass murder and
Ukraine is very poor so what the poles
can do all the Lithuanians can do which
is also to allow renovation of
synagogues to have you don't have that
in Western Ukraine it's it's very
depressing to go there because you see
collapsed synagogues you see cemeteries
being used as marketplaces or just just
just useful grazing for the local goats
and part of it is that they they started
this process much later on and they're
materially very backward still and
they're involved in other policies of
memory internal that don't exist in
places like Poland and Lithuania where
they they know who they are
and they can look back at their history
and and make claims that in Ukraine are
very difficult to make now so so in that
sense in terms of recognizing the past I
think it's there's a long way to go but
you know I I would say the same time I
mean I know a number of young and not so
young Ukrainians who would like very
much to change this and who are doing
their best it's very difficult to do now
there is an anti-semitic discourse in
Western Ukraine as there is also in
Lithuania it's very hard to do that but
I would just be careful about
generalizing because I think one has to
also work with a positive and there is a
positive there and there has been some
sort of tendency to dismiss Ukraine
completely and I don't think it says
anyone's interest to just say well the
Ukrainians forget about it there is work
to be done there and I think it can be
done and should be encouraged and then
can you like give few examples in your
research that undermines this argument
the most prominent ones so you know when
I years ago when I started thinking
about this project this was the main
question that interested me because I I
went on a tour I visited some seminars
in Germany that were friends colleagues
were teaching courses on the Holocaust
and I was interested how is that done in
Germany this is 1517 years ago and the
courses were really interesting and the
students were very dedicated and they
read a lot and the read only material
about the perpetrators
there is no memoirs they read nothing
about
they read only about Germans and when I
asked them why they said well because we
need to know why we ancestors did that
that's what we want to know I said yes
but genocide is a two-sided thing I mean
the the people kill and the people get
killed and and what about them they said
well for them they didn't exist for the
killers the Jews didn't exist they
dehumanize them so and in a sense they
accepted that argument and I thought
that once when you write about genocide
all about war for that matter about any
violence and you write about it only for
one side you aren't you become complicit
because you see things only through that
perspective and I said eh I don't think
that's really good history and B I don't
believe it's true I don't think it it
did happen it can happen but it doesn't
consistently happen and it's not that
dehumanization is is the answer that you
dehumanize a group and then what's the
problem you just killed him because you
still have to come to it to a child and
shoot them in the head and the brain
still spatter so this was the question
for me and it's a general question it's
a question about human psychology it's a
question about violence in general and
it's a question about genocide and about
the Holocaust and it was particularly
prominent in speaking about the
Holocaust and especially in Germany for
reasons that we don't have to go into
further than what I said now my sense is
that when you look balanced more closely
you will often find other types of
interaction between the killer and the
killed and what I found when I started
doing this research I just wanted to see
what was the relationship between the
the killers and the killed right but
what I found was that intimacy an
intimate relationship creates can create
proximity closeness
fashion and can create particularly
gruesome violence and I think that in
part I was influenced when I started
thinking about it also by events that
were happening at the time in Bosnia and
Rwanda where you see gratuitous violence
it's not just that you go and kill your
neighbors you rape them you you torture
them you kill the children in front of
the parents why why do you have to do
those things that's that's often part of
genocide by wine and that has to do and
I started thinking about it precisely
with the fact that you know them so it's
not just that it's easier to kill when
you dehumanize it's when you know people
the nature of the killing is different
and it's and that you can see again and
again in many genocides now in the
Holocaust we I I actually used that term
in in a book I wrote industrial killing
so we we tend to talk about industrial
killing and it is a unique aspect of the
Holocaust in terms if you compare to
other genocides but as I said much of it
didn't happen that way much of it
happened very intimately and so if you
want examples of that for me the most
striking examples are of people and and
I have several of those in my own
materials who were both killing and
keeping other potential victims in their
home and protecting them and it's this
is not only in buchiach' I mean I know
one case in fact it's a colleague now
who's whose mother was saved by an SS
officer who was involved in killing so
how do you explain that
where does dehumanization come in here
now you asked about the general thing
yes the general thing is crucial if you
want to identify where genocide is going
happen the first thing you have to look
for is that in an in a in a nation in a
state in a society you speak about one
group it's less than human once you use
that terminology it doesn't mean that
general said will happen but that's the
first step you you simply distance those
people you say okay
there they're not like us there are
cockroaches they are parasites they're
worms they're something else but they're
not fully human but as I say that's not
the end of the story that's only the
beginning all right well thank you so
much O'Meara and and please let's all
join in thanking him